what do you remember about hull which
sort of places did you go to
the place i remember most is hustle for
sure
but i just remember being back of cars
just being
raped and
sold
was it always indoors or were there
places they'd take you once i was raped
outdoors and where was that
that was hazel foreshaw
that's the beauty spot by the bridge
yeah he was saying how he could kill me
here um and bury me and no one would
realize
and then he like strangled me and
everything like just went black and i
remember i could see like the trees and
they just all went black
beauty spot ugly secret hessel foreshore
on the banks of the humber is one
location where it's alleged a gang of
men frequently raped children
we've compiled testimony from young
women whose story raises questions about
the evidence threshold police resources
in these cases and perhaps explains why
fewer than two percent of rape cases
result in charges
sarah says she was raped from the age of
13 over the course of three years up to
2019 by around 150 men once here by the
river and often in a block of flats in
the city where she says there were other
young girls i'll never forget that girl
i saw sat there in a primary school
uniform
how old
probably eight nine she was there with a
sister it was a little bit older and she
i remember screaming in that bedroom
the young women in this case provided
sky news with evidence including diaries
with accounts of grooming photos of the
bruising and strangulation marks that
it's claimed were caused by the men and
school welfare reports which flag
numerous warnings of child exploitation
including threats from alleged abusers
one here seen by a teacher
but a two-year investigation ended
without charges humberside police say 34
arrests and 150 devices seized didn't
provide evidence of organized child
sexual exploitation known as cse
we've seen social services file that
says that a girl was found in locations
well known for cse in hull so are then
as are there locations that are well
known for cse in hall we will have as
part of our police and delivery hot
spots where we get reports in and then
we put the patrols in those areas and do
those investigations to confirm whether
or not we've got wide-scale cse
in relation to um this investigation we
can say we've got no organized
criminality within homicide police whole
area for cse
there is plenty of reported child abuse
in the two years to march 2020
humberside police recorded 458 rapes of
a female aged 15 or under a fraction
resulted in charges
drug given alcohol
you know sexually assaulted physically
assaulted the uk's most senior retired
police officer in the field of child
exploitation has examined over a
thousand documents in this case for us
and concludes the evidence is strong
there's significant corroboration from a
number of victims about individual
predators so it's not just he said she
said we've got a number of victor
victims saying here's the pattern of
behavior it's identical and this is the
person that does it is your gut feeling
that this this case should be tested in
court
oh absolutely
i mean
if they need additional evidence
then go out and get it we're almost at
the point where we need to declare war
on this type of behavior we need to say
it is a priority
in a series of reports this week we will
examine the evidence and testimony of
these alleged victims for the people of
hull the biggest question is whether
this gang was doing this and are they
still
jason farrell sky news
well you can see more of jason's special
reports from one o'clock tomorrow
afternoon and throughout the rest of the
day here on sky news